[Music]
hey there I'm Ryan Reynold star of the
upcoming film if and if you've ever uh
and I'm John krinski the director and
star of the upcoming film if wa wa hold
on what are you
doing I'm talking about our movie you're
not you're not John krinski you're
Randall Park John krinski is much
shorter and less Asian than you are uh
Ryan I know it's been a while since we
shot but we spent like 4 months together
like 10hour day 10 hours the real John
krinski knows that I only work four
hours a day did you just break the
fourth wall I was trying to Ryan who are
you married to Emily Blunt well you just
looked that up on on on Wikipedia where
were you born boston Wikipedia did you
not see the behind the scenes video okay
you know what the sneak peek can wait
until Sunday so Ryan and everyone please
enjoy our behind the-scenes video of Me
John krinski and Ryan Reynolds you're
not John
CHR what are you anyway and
if I had the idea for this movie about 7
years ago and uh I wanted to do a movie
about imaginary friends called
it imaginary friend got
it this is the movie that John and I
I've been talking about for years now
something that feels a bit like a
liveaction Pixar
film the movie is about a little girl
named bee going through an experience in
her life that's troubling and as a
coping mechanism she starts to see every
single person's imaginary friend
hi it's about that friend that's there
for them unconditionally and always get
it imaginary friend that's enough sorry
sorry it's just so exciting stop that is
too good okay we're
[Music]
done
he